excuse me you look a little hungry there
could I perhaps interest you in a snack
have you tried the new sand pockets
they're delicious give them a go hmm no
not your flavor have you tried the new
VHS static flavor tastes just like ants
oh really you're a snob huh well how
about a hot pocket package pocket now
that's matter Oh No well how about a hot
pocket snails
that's for my haters it's still crispy
and buttery no well how about hot pocket
caviar with quail eggs and breathe I see
I can tell that you are a person of a
finer taste because oh boy that looks
delicious okay now if you don't want any
of these flavors I don't know what to
tell you okay you're gonna have to just
decide on something please these and
used medical needles okay we're running
out of flavors here please all right I
think I know what you want I can tell by
looking you in the eyes what you want
there's hot pocket dry or late listen up
listen up you don't know if you don't
like it unless you tried it give it a go
it's nice and steamy it's nice and soft
it makes your mouth feel like dust enjoy
you want gluten-free you want dairy-free
you want eggs brie you want me free you
want food free and you want water free
anyone air please enjoy how about the
blank PNG please accept dip lick
excuse me for getting angry you're a man
of culture a mane of the finer finer
finer tastes I know just the thing
anime fights that's right everybody
anime Thanks mmm doesn't get any more
delish than some anime thighs just so
nice who love who doesn't love a thigh
especially if it's from an anime picture
emotional s void because that is what
you are
if you won't have my pot pockets I don't
know what to tell you
maybe you want the Africa flavored
edition nothing how about a cancer cell
hug pockets
how much can I keep literally there's
just an effing dog in there I'm not
hotpokket I'm John I had enough there's
only so much a man can endure the hot
pockets mean this is an older me which
is why there's so many iterations but
they really just never end it's one of
those memes I just keep on floating
until I got my hands on it I gots a six
I quite like it I never actually had a
hot pocket are they are they good which
flavour would you pick leave a comment
down below next mean this mean guys is
blowing up prepare for blowing up me
montage this is going to be great do you
have a better idea
yes I do I'm Kraft Seto
where you need to survive all day and
all night craft a diamond sword so you
can fire if anyone has a question hey do
you have a better idea what we can do
just hit him with this hit him with that
minecraft theto Enderdragon in my
direction
min exp it's such a blessing yeah he's
all the XP to enchant my armor yeah
gotta kill them so I can go too bad this
armors really comfy when I put it on
I see a village that is near the only
son someone in here with the games no
that's what the iron so I think it's saw
metal make another [ __ ] back at Omega
that I got a magnet that I made that man
oh yeah I said a message it was he
playing this whole time
Alexa shut the [ __ ] up Jesus Christ no
one I literally know what Alexa no one
where would say do you have a better
eyes you have a better idea just never
have a better idea
do you have a better idea yes I do
okay what is it gonna play you're in the
trenches it's World War one the Germans
are coming what are you
Alexa plane will punt gunman Stan do you
have a better idea
yes I do yes what is happening help me
supposed to review the means do you have
a better idea
yes I do oh my god the ally a meme Shh
never seen that one do you have a better
idea
yes I do I have been in this space
before huh I don't mean it's really not
working mega rate this meme gets us
fights yes I do
zero Alexa play zero
Alexa what would you rate this mean
Alexa are you actually mean review
YouTube's me missed show everybody we
got means alright Alexa how old is Amy
Schumer okay all right just shut up for
a second Alexa what is the average
lifespan of a blue whale no no no Alexa
this is so sad
can we play just by sequel number why
volume to the max many XP is such a
blessing yeah these are the XP to
enchant my armor yeah
try to sleep my darkest day how old is
the rock 46 years
how long does rocks live no not the
Dwayne the rock Johnson Who am I going
to watch fight a giant creature climb a
giant tower or just do something that I
don't really care about damn it this is
so sad Alexa can we onions please I
didn't ask how long just ice cream last
no two to three months Oh No why do
people have to die Alexa how old is no
pump he was born on the 17th shut up
shut up shut up shut up shut up what is
the life expectancy of pumps 18 years
ma ma person everybody can we get a
thousand likes on this video cuz he's
about to get mad and I bet you he is not
even going to heaven
how old is Eminem forty five years how
long do mmm sleep know they do the
action in live before no they don't
that's fake how old is pitbull Oh No
people's lives only 37 years this is so
sad wait he's actually only 37 I thought
it was like 57
how long does Barry be Benson live only
one more day apparently how old is the
how old is me three days how long do
memes live in 2018
two to five days well bonus point for
this meme for being extra woke because
that's that's pretty true and you don't
see a lot of memes icing more than a
week these days some just sort of come
and go I don't know dude that right how
old is the girl reading this around 20
years how long does an angel live oh how
old is the person watching this video
nine years how old just epic people that
smash like on the video live for
ever that's amazing dude I feel great
about this I have a good feeling about
this relationship
how old is Tom Cruise average length of
the average length of cruises is nearly
seven days this makes zero sense what
the heck I have a meme is going to be
funny at least make it funny how all
this beauty pie 28 years
how long do pies live ah no ah damn it
ah Alexa this is so sad for real
can we play an actual sad song that
makes everyone just feels like do you
know what this was a bit of a trash meme
episode but at least I can embrace this
melancholic feeling thank you guys for
watching another episode of me review
I'm your host Felix Kajal Burke and I'll
see you guys next time
[Music]